Here's a sketch of the algorithm as we were just running it by hand.
Largely, we're trying to find shortest distances from D to the other nodes in the graph.
we initialize D's distance to V as 0, then we imagine that all the other distances
to all the other nodes in the graph were as yet unknown, and each time we go through the loop,
that there's still nodes left that haven't been completed yet.
We find the node with the shortest known distance and then we locked it down.
By marking it as known and then going through the list of its edges--all that edges out of W--
for example, just some other node and we check if the new distance, the distance to W
that we just locked down plus the weight of the edge from W to X.
If that improves on the best known distance to X, then we update X's distance to be this new value.
And once we've done that for all the neighbors of W, then we could finished W
and we go back up to this loop and say not all nodes are complete.
You get a new W, a new shortest distance to lock down. So that's the basic structure.
Let's actually look at that in--I'm going to say Python.